the las vegas convention center is
entering a new era when it comes to
health and technology
it will be the first convention center
in the world to offer on med it's a
high-tech virtual health care station
hector mejia live from the convention
center with a look at that hey hector
this sounds really cool
hey there we're inside the booth it
looks like a booth it's really high-tech
and really futuristic it basically
connects
convention goers and employees virtually
with a healthcare provider
joining us this afternoon to talk about
the high-tech features in here we have
austin white ceo of onmed
good afternoon to you sir thank you
hector good afternoon so what makes this
so high-tech well this ties in
telemedicine with virtual calls
with a telehealth provider and the
ability to dispense medications at point
of access
what are we looking at right now coming
down from the ceiling this would be a
high definition handheld autofocus
camera that looks into your
eyes ears nose throat and skin with a 4k
technology in high def what does this
allow
a person walking inside do when they
interact with a medical professional
it takes telehealth to the next level in
diagnostic capability
the opportunities for a stethoscope to
be listening to your ears
i mean to your heart and lung sounds
along with a
high definition thermography camera
detect your temperature
your height weight your blood pressure
your pulse your pulse oximetry
gives the clinician significant amount
of diagnostic capability
in order to give you a proper diagnosis
and prescribe the proper medication
so as i'm trying to i get a close-up
view of my hand here
um trying to use this here on my hand
just just put it right on your skin so
we are talking also with a medical
provider right in front of us on this
screen and uh what is this used for
to let's say maybe look inside your ear
or look at the back of someone's throat
the back of your throat the eye
certainly the skin for a dermatological
appointment
uh there's you can put that right up to
your eye there you go
wow okay
all right so you know i'm actually
touching everything how does this get
sanitized you know we likely have people
who are not feeling well walking inside
it's a great question so what we do is
we have ionized air that purifies the
air
consistently and at the end of every
visit we leave all the diagnostic
equipment hanging
down and we operate a uvc
light fixture that kills c diff in three
minutes
so this will be the cleanest environment
that any patient comes into next to a
surgical or
wow thank you so much for your time and
also it'll be able to
dispense the medication as well down
here after having that interaction
with a medical provider reporting from
the convention
center hector mejia back to you hector
we are all in the studio
so amazed by this this is so cool so
when will this be operational and where
will these be located do we know
we do actually very soon it'll actually
be
operational uh by june 8th that's when
world of concrete opens so it'll be
ready and open just in time for that
large convention that's coming back to
town
wow that'll be cool it's also located in
the north hall inside the convention
center
okay so the north hall so it's not just
that one next to you there's going to be
several
is that right just one just one but this
one unit can see two patients at a time
and it's located here inside the north
hall we have
we're taking a short walk here to show
you uh the other side of this to
so you can see how high tech this is and
all the moving parts
that go along with this wow that is so
cool hector what a game changer
thank you so much that'll be a big deal
for will the concrete that'll be the
first
big event there in over a year so thank
you hector good work out there